sir david attenborough gazes down on a
street in dublin's portobello the 2019
mural was painted to celebrate his 93rd
birthday but it's now at the center of a
legal battle it was painted by the art
collective subset who also created a
mural of uk rapper stormzy
but along with two other murals like
horseboy the attenborough work was
created without permission from dublin
city council who decided to prosecute
one of subset's co-founders they remain
anonymous in public
told us of the toll it's taken
we always say it's so serious it's a
joke
so it's very difficult very stressful
the impact it has on the crew our
resources our time our energy
and
yeah it's difficult
this is not vandalism we paint with the
permission of property owners but in
ireland you also need planning
permission to create a mural
subset says the law is outdated and
needs to be overhauled it wants
regulation like that in sydney where
murals can be created with just the
building owner's consent as long as it's
not offensive you know our ultimate
motivation is a change in legislation
which will
as far as we're concerned be a catalyst
for
you know
more creative exploits
the city council told us it can't
comment on the subset case because it's
still before the courts but broadly
speaking the council says it is
supportive of public art installations
in the right appropriate locations the
council says it's approved no fewer than
35 large-scale works in the past year
alone
murals and other street art have
proliferated in ireland in recent years
owen conlon guides walking tours of
dublin's street art and says it helps
reduce anti-social behavior
this public art gallery brings people
down this lane constantly before there
would have been not many people visiting
this laneway now there is always
hundreds of people in that traffic just
reduces the issues that would have been
found here the case against subset has
now been adjourned until september you
know as far as we're concerned now it's
just bite down on the gum shield and
finish off the fight
and as far as you're concerned that only
ends with a change in the law yeah 100
it's a struggle between freedom of
expression and the regulation of civic
space played out against a very public
backdrop
stephen murphy sky news dublin